Carson Palmer is sticking with us for
another segment here courtesy of FedEx
and joining us as well now my compadre
from the NFL Network NFL Media Group NFL
gameday morning part of our draft
coverage tonight I'll be hanging out
with Steve Smith senior and also with
Troy Aikman so come say hi when Steve's
on the set yes merrier I brought my tie
as well rich and I don't know what you
guys are a little underdressed well no
this is this yeah it's a casual Thursday
I like that but you I mean must be
frying huge mooch like why are you all
suited and but you're not on the air for
another four hours life is different I
got to do the pregame show I'm all about
you what I'm on that too I thought we
were on the air like yet like one
o'clock or so are you really you're out
yeah I don't know I'm working today rich
I don't know what you're doing hey buddy
I will say this yes I didn't go over to
that experience I just came right right
straight through here yeah and you know
I know Jerry Jones wants to double the
attendance from Philadelphia like a
couple hundred thousand right yeah but
you know what Dallas fans you better
show up because you need right now I'm
just looking out here there's a lot but
Philly was like tight sardines
I don't move you got it you got some
catching up to do look at mooch calling
out the people he's down with and Browns
fans what do you think they get Baker
Mayfield tonight Steve gosh that's the
route that's the orders every day things
change you leave that though I don't I
don't believe it I think it's just
smokes me I think there's a lot of poker
playing going on in the last week or two
and yeah I I i don't i now know Baker
Mayfield I like the kid he's gonna get
drafted hi I hope he has a great career
I don't think they're gonna do that
number one maybe I'm wrong but we were
just talking with Carson there was no
intrigue with you right there was no I
mean was there any point in time you
thought you were not gonna go to the
Cincinnati Bengals no I mean I thinking
back as soon as we played in the Orange
Bowl I felt like the talk had already
started and it was pretty much a done
deal and nothing ever really changed
throughout the process for me yeah well
you know it was different your year
because you signed and agreed with the
Bengals
before the draft did you did you have a
contract
I did how many games before the draft so
I flew from California the draft was on
that day I flew from California to Ohio
probably on Wednesday or Thursday and
did the deal sign the deal met everybody
did the tour did all that stuff and then
flew from from Ohio New York and really
had a good time in New York no stress I
already knew what was going on
family friends were there and then so
the draft happens and every player goes
there which way wherever they get
drafted they head to that city and then
do the media - I'd already done the
media tour I'd already sign the contract
so I got to stay in New York and have a
great long weekend did you if my friends
and family in New York it was great it's
great well I remember that very well
because I was in Detroit then so we had
the next pick in the draft so we had all
that time really essentially other than
you we had we had to pick of the litter
right well he had the pick of whichever
wide receiver Matt Millen wanted you to
taste and we took this Michigan State
guy right Charles Rogers remember that
oh that's a Charles rod okay now I'm
just trying to figure the time line
Carson you were too young to be on the
cowl radar screen right when you were at
count
he was probably walked in over at SC
from day one right what year did you did
you go to s edu I got there in 98 you
were already gone I was gone
I don't recruit you karin-san friend
yeah I was at Cal at 96 so you were on
our on our recruiting board as a
youngster okay
Rancho Santa Margarita that's right baby
Eagles well what do you think Carson to
this conversation that we're constantly
having about putting a college football
style RPO is into into the National
Football League and the the transferring
of of power if you will from
quarterbacks like someone like yourself
tall big arm guy to people like Baker
Mayfield
and obviously the Mar Jackson tonight do
you think that that is going to be the
future of the NFL and quarterbacks like
you will have
fewer and fewer opportunities I don't
think it's the future it's a couple
things where I mean one I would not want
Baker in that system he's not a good
enough runner I don't think you would
want him running it half the time
throwing it the other half would win
that play called it comes up but Lamar
can absolutely do it but his
aggressiveness and the style of runner
he is I don't like it at all he's a
physical runner he lowers his shoulder
he lowers his head he doesn't slide he
doesn't get down he takes a Punnett he
gives a punishing or attend gives a
punishment but also takes a punishment
at this next level when he's 215 pounds
and he's getting hit by 240 of 250 pound
guys I don't think that translates well
for you know for him having a nice long
healthy career so I worry about that a
guy like Russell Wilson who is so sneaky
and savvy and gets down and slides and
doesn't you know doesn't take those hits
I think it's perfect for his style of
running ability but not for Baker and
and Lamar is probably the best runner
we've seen since Mike Vick come out but
Lamar runs different Lamar takes hits
Lamar puts his shoulder in the
linebackers in the NFL that's just a bad
that's a bad recipe yeah but if I if I
were taking Lamar and he's gonna be on a
team okay I would make cut-ups I would
make a cut up of Russell Wilson doing
exactly what you just said Carson
protecting himself
sliding early getting out of bounds
throwing the ball away all of those
things to stay alive all right but also
make a cut up of right
rg3 rg3 had a heck of a rookie year he
survived that year but boy it was used
taking a lot of hits he got hit so many
times because he was trying to be that
tough guy and in trying to get that
extra yard and all that and even in
survive health well I remember he took
that hit from Haloti Ngata
where he was on the sidelines taking on
the Ravens and he got blown up by Haloti
Ngata when he could have easily avoided
it just taking one step to his left and
it got to the point where even Obama was
telling RG 3f
out of balance at one point the leader
of the free world started chiming in
help say because it was obvious to
everybody you if you want to play in
this league you got a darn well protect
yourself these otherwise you're gonna be
watching on Sundays from your couch and
so that's what so that's what I would do
Lamar
you can go this way or you can go this
way you decide how long you want play
but that's so hard to coach that that
innate ability for him - he's running
powers and traps in college and coming
downhill and and to then tell a kid that
that has had so much success you need to
change the way you run the ball it's
just you can't coach that that
aggressiveness that that innate ability
to get and get in the middle of the hole
and pick a guy and put your head in the
middle of his chest and run him over
it's just so hard to then say okay now
you're in the NFL now you have to slide
that's a totally different mentality
that's a totally different way of
playing the game that's what worries me
so much about Lamar's you just can't you
can show him a ton of cut-ups but at the
end of the day when he's in the game in
the heat of the moment he's gonna
naturally revert back to I'm gonna lower
my shoulder and you're putting your
shoulder into into the guys that were
twins
25 35 45 pounds more than you that
there's issues there durability was
interesting that that Carson farmers
Steve Mariucci together a couple more
minutes and then moot you're gonna hang
here for the rest of the hour they might
you know Lamar might not have to have
cut ups made of rg3 he might just have
to turn to his right were left in the
quarterback room well I'm way out thinks
that the Ravens are gonna be the team
that takes him off the board tonight at
16 do you think that'd be an interesting
thing like I guess any place that takes
him is gonna have to uh I loved watching
him play you can't stop watching his
film he is like oh dynamic and so
explosive and such a better athlete than
everybody around him on the field but at
the same time I don't want to see him
doing that in the NFL I see him throw
the ball and everyone live examples too
he keeps saying that though I'm not a
runner he doesn't you refused to even
run a 40-yard dash at his pro day yeah
but he won the Heisman running the
football anyone had thrown it but he
took off and ran and you people with his
legs who did you vote for the Heisman
over him
Oh again this year yeah this year I
voted for Baker this year he did for the
voted for him last year
do you know Carson how many
a career rushing yards you that heaven
you asked me this I may I may have but
I'm bringing if it's a goodie to bring
it back again I've been I've been hit
let's see who lets you can get Price is
Right rules closest without going over
Steve Mariucci and Carson Palmer the
Carson your first how many career
rushing or the mooches stop mooch how
many career us know if you're negative
then I win on 0 so I might be [ __ ] I
hope I'm not negative I'm gonna say
you're not negative you've got a career
amount of positive rushing yards here
yeah you know why for ten working what
touchdowns no no no come on now
they're my real rushing yards am i not
double digits is abate no come on you're
you've got boots are the sacs take away
no no we're not to see in college it
does no sax no no no no sacks are
against your past you had you had you
had you had 301 career rushing attempts
I don't believe it that's a true story
those are the stamps hey man you had 179
rushing attempts as a Bengal okay so but
that's like rushing at a time figuring
out quarterback sneak and write 474
rushing yards career career shocking
averaging one point six yards per carry
yeah it's not talking about- almost 1/5
of a first down every time you decided
myself real quick is that we're all
having fun with this slow I am I bet I
ran a faster I could run the 40 I know
it's faster than you that boy lag but I
bet I ran faster than Jim is that guy
wishes we tweak we confer what do you
want to know what you ran a 40-yard dash
in economy at like four six eight or my
did Chris figure that out we could do I
think I at the combo we not talk about
rushing yards Queen contrabass man 40
yeah sure at least run a 40 you ran a
for what at the combine six eight six
nine four six 0.65 Wow boom closest
without going over
I like it that's awesome that's all i
annoy
yeah so 413 yards rushing for how many
years x8 15 by the way so in 15 years
you only had 470 yards more rushing than
me by the way by the way you're you
don't to one hundredth of a second
slower than Larry Fitzgerald it's 40
are you aware is this being taped damn
Carson Palmer
you should have ran a little bit more
you won the Heisman hey last one for you
are you are you interested in getting in
the meeting I'm interested in a lot of
different things a post
post-playing career yeah it's something
I'm looking at and I've been looking at
a bunch of different stuff okay I'm what
I'm trying not to do is make a decision
I kind of told my wife and my kids it'd
give me six months to kind of I've just
been listening and learning and vetting
yeah but yeah I'm taking my sweet time
to figure out what's next okay well it's
great to see you it's great to see it to
see you let me know hey let me know if
I'm ever gonna look to my left in my
right room anytime Carson you move to
Idaho so that I don't have that way I
use you know my wife and I love going to
Idaho we love it we loved it when you
came on our podcast yeah I'll see you
when I see you good Carson Palmer we're
on an Idaho all the time it's beautiful
up there yeah if you see a Carson Palmer
here part of FedEx good to see you Steve
Mary don't you dare move to me and mooch
when we come back in 60 seconds hear
from the NFL experience at the track
you're listening to the Rich Eisen show
all right we are back here at the
courtyard hotels experience at the NFL
Draft more and more fans are coming to
say hello to us it's great always to to
see them that Prescott's gonna be
stopping by later not on our show but
he's gonna be stopping by later I think
he's gonna be very popular Steve
Mariucci equally as popular right now
that's right right here in the Metroplex
so you are in that draft room at
Cleveland tonight you are the coach of
the Cleveland Browns I'm making you the
coach the Cleveland Browns
what do you tell John Dorsey before he
pulls the trigger what do you say help
me help me help you and I know both
these guys pretty darn well I was with
John Dorsey in Green Bay
I was a coach he was over there on the
west wing with Ron wolf skies sure and
he was an Andy Reid guys we all know
proportion and then and then Hugh
Jackson was my offensive coordinator at
Cal so we go way back to so these guys
are both very competent and what they do
right and they're very secretive about
what they're gonna do to I mean I don't
need to know if people in the building
know what they're gonna so what's your
sea is like you've got Jarvis Landry and
you've got you've got Josh Gordon what
are you what are you which is the
quarterback you think is the quarterback
you if you were the coach Steve Mariucci
you would push for it well I like so
they have a quarterback in place now
with Tyrod Taylor's yesterday to hold
down the fort and that guy led Buffalo
now to the playoffs and that's not an
easy task why are you not answering my
question
so which means that they can draft a guy
I will I'll get to it that can I hope
you can sit around you watch Tyrod be a
pro yes you might not have the same
plane style and athleticism is Tyrod but
you watch and prepare you watch him
practice you want to talk about defenses
and blitzes and all of that sort of
thing so hopefully this youngster won't
have to play like DeSean Kaiser did last
year yes
so it's you know cut to the chase I
would take the most complete quarterback
in the draft
to me it's Sam don't Donald it's it's
from SC where Carson Palmer was from
right he doesn't have the strongest arm
of the group let's let's talk about the
big five if you want to include right
Lamar Jackson
yes he does Sam Darnell doesn't have the
strongest arm Josh Allen does he doesn't
have the best mobility but he has good
mobility he's you know he the Knicks on
him you know he gets a little sloppy
with the ball at times and turns it over
you know you got to coach him up to keep
some hands on the ball and protect it
and himself but but I think he's
probably very ready to do this and he's
that kind of guy you know what I had
some and and I think it's a fit maybe we
use that that term a little bit too
loosely sometimes right a fit mean
what's up
bitte right well you know I talked to
that when we were doing this last year
there were two quarterbacks right yes
Goffin wins in talking to their to their
people they asked what do you think
mooch
what's the evaluation and it's part of
its the evaluation of what they can do
and what they can't do but the other
part of its a fit and I told less need I
said less here's my thought I said the
fit for for for the Rams in LA is Jared
Goff because he's a California kid
right and he's and I think I think the
fit will be good I think you'd be
well-received I think it I think he'll
be you know comfortable there and at
home because he is at home wait at Marin
Catholic and then they Aikau
alright and I said for Carson Wentz who
I love he's kind of a blue-collar guy a
tough guy from North Dakota state that
fit to be with those Eagles in that fan
basin in in that environment I think
that's a good fit too and if you switch
them if you switch them they would have
been successful I think sure no but it
seemed to be a good fit so so to me the
Cleveland Browns and Sam Darnell is a
good fit I would go that way too and you
would say that just you would say that's
a John Dorsey absolutely okay call him
right now if you want if what do you say
about the Mayfield Rosen choice that the
Jets that's a harder one for me because
I don't know if I don't know what the
best fit in New York
well you've hired Jeremy Bates is your
quarterbacks coach and your offensive
coordinator because because Baker
Mayfield and Josh Rosen are two
different this is a bulls and oranges
now but you know the offense that Bates
runs and the type of coach that he is I
do and he's a good coach but he's gonna
have to be a flexible coach and I think
that's the trend right now I think if
you spend a lot of money on a type of
quarterback right you've got a run an
offense that he can be proficient at
alright and the change your ways a
little bit if you need to and we saw
that with the Eagles in Nick Foles
running more of his Chip Kelly stuff
that he was good at and I think coaches
are gonna learn from that you know when
I was coaching it was going to be I like
the West Coast offense and you better
learn it or get out I'm gonna get
somebody else that can run it
sort of you know yeah but I think now if
there's an athletic quarterback or a
smaller quarterback like Baker Mayfield
you better adjust your offense
accordingly otherwise you what do you
want to bust you want to coach a bust or
do you want to coach somebody that can
do what you do all right I want to take
a break come back in my last segment
with you before I send you to the NFL
Network compound fully dressed way too
early I do want to hit you up on what
you think the evaluation of Josh Allen
might be right now yeah what you as a
coach if you fell in love with a guy
like this might be doing and also just
your history of being in a draft room I
want I want a good story of an argument
or a big moment or something I'm
thinking and I promise you I'm not going
to ask you for the giovani car mazi
story I just did that for Jim
Druckenmiller Oh dr. doreen can you tell
us that oh yeah
okay very good that's next here on the
Rich Eisen yes you're listening to the
Rich Eisen
okay we are back here live at the NFL
Draft want to tell you about Steve
Mariucci favorite pillow my pillow did
you bring one on the road Steve no but I
learned that they have a travel little
pillow there my bag next time we call
them go anywhere pillows and you can get
two of those with to my pillow premium
pillows 40% off of them it's the four
pack special when you go to my pillow
comm and you put my name rich in the
promo code spot when you click on the
radio listener special tab so go to my
pillow comm radio listener special tab
put in the promo code rich and you get
the four pack special you love these I'm
gonna do it now you did you get freebies
oh when you came on my show and no rich
I haven't had a three night stay at
court yard yeah how long now you have
come on I know how about a pillow I got
you back I got your back
alright I've got I've got about five and
change left I want to get all this what
do you think is going down in the draft
room of any coach who loves Josh Allen
right now huh I mean everybody loves
them and so this news that broke is uh
it's very interesting very crazy
obviously it's very difficult to try and
figure out what to make of it yeah I
know it and it was something that
happened when he was what a freshman in
high school or something like that it
goes back so so if it's somebody that I
I'm interested in taking which there are
several teams that would love him
you start making phone calls because
this is new news it's this didn't
surface until last night and so you
start making phone calls and try to find
out from coaches teammates high school
friends secretaries whoever right start
talking to as many people did this ever
show up in his behavior or was it
there's a tweeting don't you know would
have been found already
yes point in time yes but that's what
that's why it's so surprising right
because it sounds like it was something
crazy that was going on maybe with some
tweeting back and forth with some people
and all of a sudden but that's not how
he lived his life or how he treated his
teammates or her people or women or her
friends or anything because it was it
was so not him and so I I think they're
going to have to
triple check and make sure that he is
who they think he is right and and so in
its it would be a shame if he starts
sliding like crazy because of something
like this without great explanation
it's unfortunate man it's like who dug
this stuff up from my ears and then it
and then it comes out again the night
before the draft and it's something that
again I'll be talking about with Michael
with Mike Freeman of bleacher report
next hour give us the latest on his
draft status David Shaw of Stanford's
gonna join us as well as he coaches in
your own neck of the woods there and
we're neighbor in in Stanford so there's
a good Druckenmiller story that you can
actually tell here on the Rich Eisen
show know there's some good drug stories
that I'm not going to tell all of them
or well we've got it I will tell you
this okay you can you can can appreciate
this but I will tell you that Jim
Druckenmiller yes from Virginia Tech is
probably the reason why we didn't pursue
and draft your guy from Michigan Tom
Brady yeah you say what you need an
explanation right rich please so here's
what happened we dropped the drug I
don't know 28th pick in the draft right
late in the first and and we still had
Steve Young and we as coaches figured
well we got to make this guy one of our
one of our quarterbacks that can do what
we do in the West Coast offense and in
the West Coast offense you like to move
those guys Steve Young as Baker may feel
sighs pretty much okay so you move him
you don't let them play from the pocket
the entire game you change the launch
point and you in your movement and play
action and keep packages very diverse
alright well we learned that that's not
drugs deal okay he's not going to be
able to it you'd have to play from the
pocket right wrong guy so I'm running a
very pretty girlfriend and all that
stuff right okay so so so we ended up
releasing him and deciding that we you
don't want to go down that path again
with the category of drop-back passer
which Tom Brady was in rich and more of
the athletic kind of mobile guy that
runs fast I had no idea Carson Palmer
ran for six five I had no idea either
you could
we over for the feather so you went with
the the future goat shepherd your body
Kumasi instead I don't want to sit here
and defend Geo car mozzie all right
oh you've dropped him cuz he's an
Italian guy right what so this kid was a
Rhodes Scholar
this kid was the point guard in the
basketball team this guy was at four six
or seven athlete he was he was all of
that he was like whoa whoa and it's like
hey you're defending Giovanni Carmen I
said we said we can mold this guy we can
mold him into one of these guys and he
we're not in a hurry because Steve's
gonna be around another ten years well
you know he was short in the confidence
and intangible part of it well sure yeah
by the way molding Giovanni it was a
great movie from the makers of Howard
ten it was a little bit too art housey
for me moulding Giovanni
good job mooch farmers oh man love you
man love you managers I'm buying here
I'm gonna use this suit because I have a
show how old is that photograph on your
on your I told Alex on the way here I
said this is this was taken like the
second day I was on board 13 years ago
can you change my photo you look you
haven't changed you haven't shared that
you might not even I mean with my photo
I might not even be let in the building
on my credential you guys like this Rich
Eisen beard kind of scruffy look or not
oh yeah I'm saying that it's part of the
rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience